so a lot of people don't realize just
how big the post credit scene for echko
is now we won't really dive too much
into spoilers for The Echo series if you
have not seen every episode yet so don't
worry we're going to do a review about
it later but I did want to tackle the
post credit scene in this video and it's
really setting up quite a bit of
different shows and movies coming up in
the MCU but specifically it is really
setting up Kingpin to be the new Thanos
of the street level of the MCU and
yesterday's video we talked about how
Marvel Studios is really branching off
into different areas different sides of
the MCU we have the street level
Avengers team we're going to have the
supernatural team the cosmic team X-Man
Fantastic 4 Etc and it's really cool
because they're each going to have their
own big bads of those sections of the
MCU and Kingpin is the big bad of the
street side of the MCU or what Kevin
fige refers to as the more grounded side
of the MCU and since we've seen Kingpin
enter the MCU in haaka and now an echo
he has been the head of his own crime
organization in fact the first thing
that he says in the post credit scene is
I want a meeting with all the remaining
heads and what he's speaking of is the
people who really work for him the heads
of different parts of his organization
also you have to keep in mind if you
have not heard the Daredevil Netflix
series is now Canon to the MCU meaning
everything that took place everything
that happened in the Daredevil series
with Daredevil and with Kingpin that is
all now a part of the MC and you should
treat that like it actually was released
on Disney plus by Marvel Studios in the
MCU because that is essentially what it
is now in fact Disney plus has even put
all of the defender Netflix series on
Disney plus and actually if you go in
and you look in the different sections
and you look at the Timeline order you
can see that Daredevil Jessica Jones and
others have actually been added to the
MCU timeline Daredevil followed by
Jessica Jones right after has been added
right after Guardians of the Galaxy
volume 2 and I am Groot it goes
Guardians of the Galaxy Volume 2 I am
Groot Daredevil Jessica Jones Avengers
Age of Ultron Antman then Luke Cage
ironfist and the Defenders then if you
go all the way down to Spider-Man
homecoming you can see that the Punisher
sits between Spider-Man homecoming and
Doctor Strange so make no mistake these
Marvel Netflix shows that we had are now
a part of the MCU so all of the events
that took place in these shows take
place in the MCU so Kingpin is a huge
Crime Boss Of course but now this post
credit scene he's about to take it even
a step further and this ties right into
the events of not only Daredevil born
again but also the new Spider-Man coming
out with Tom Holland Spider-Man 4
Kingpin is going to run for mayor of New
York City but real quick let's talk
about what he refers to as the situation
spiraling out of control he needs to
meet with the other heads before it gets
out of his control basically what he is
speaking of is his crime organization
essentially falling apart since the
events of Ekko this is why he needs to
meet with the other heads to make sure
his whole entire organization isn't
going to fall to the ground and he is
left with nothing which is also why when
he sees the TV about the mayor election
it's very appealing to him he looks at a
TV on his private plane and it says NYC
race for mayor no clear front runner he
hasn't a mute but it catches his
attention then he turns up the volume
and we hear the host say describe their
ideal candidate speaking of people
talking about who their ideal candidate
would be it turns out most people would
want somebody who is a fighter which
works against the career politicians
meaning it works against pretty much the
people who are currently running for
mayor of New York including the current
mayor of New York City which of course
catches kingpin's attention because
that's who he is he's a fighter he's
Scrappy I mean the dude got shot in the
face and he's still alive and that is
most certainly something that he is
going to use in his mayoral campaign I'm
sure he's going to say the crime in the
city is so bad he got shot in the face
but he survived and now he wants to
clean it up I'm sure that's going to be
a big push for him a big selling point
for him to become the mayor of New York
City Plus not to mention in this we have
seen especially in that first episode
just how much of an influence Kingpin
has on the people of New York including
the police we saw him in the beginning
basically go up to Maya who was being
arrested was being held down by two cops
he just walks up he takes her puts her
in his car the police just stand back
and watch and they're basically like
yeah that's Kingpin do what he said says
don't get in his way if he wants that
girl let him take her One Cop even tells
another cop do you have any idea who
that is basically Kingpin with his heads
and the rest of his organization are
already running New York City but now
Kingpin has the idea to actually run New
York City as the mayor of New York City
the host continued to say that the
people want somebody who understands the
pain that they're going through and they
say a bare knuckle brawler would do good
in this race and again the wheels are
turning in kingpin's head he's going
that is me someone who is not afraid to
take on the establishment and one of the
hosts says but wouldn't that person
would have already come out by now
wouldn't they have already announc that
they are running for mayor and they ask
that if a candidate like this even
exists and that if he does it's not too
late in the process there's still time
for a candidate to come out and run for
mayor then Kingpin leans forward staring
into the TV thinking about what he just
heard and this is the moment he decides
he is going to run for mayor of New York
City he is going to rule new New York
City by the book and also not by the
book with his crime organization and
like I said this is going to play deeply
into Daredevil born again and Spiderman
4 specifically because in Daredevil Born
Again Kingpin will become mayor now
based off of what we've heard from some
insiders Kingpin is seemingly going to
give it a shot at trying to become
legitimate like he's going to
legitimately try to be a good mayor and
clean up the city and kind of try to
abide by some ethics he's basically
going to give it a real shot and this
might be due to some of the trauma that
he has been forced to relive throughout
the echo series again no spoilers really
but even in the trailer they showed us
the past of Kingpin and how he still
does have some trauma based off of what
has happened to him when he was a boy so
perhaps this trauma that he's been
dealing with is going to cause him to
try to be a legitimate mayor of New York
City and try to do some good however
we've also heard that it doesn't really
last we don't know why maybe he just
turns we know he's not going to be the
only villain of Daredevil born again but
one big thing that we heard is he is
going to make a law against being a
vigilante which obviously affects Matt
Murdoch and daredevil on the two
different levels Matt Murdoch as a
lawyer because he'll probably have to
represent some Vigilantes and of course
it affects him as Daredevil a vigilante
himself this is also where we get into
Spider-Man no way home Spider-Man is in
New York and Kingpin is going to be the
mayor a crime boss is going to be the
mayor of New York City this definitely
affects Spider-Man since one he is a
vigilante and Kingpin is going to make
that illegal and two of course Kingpin
is a classic Spider-Man villain we are
finally diving into a true Sinister 6
era of Spider-Man in the MCU in fact I'm
sure some of the other heads that he has
as a part of his organization could be
members of the Sinister 6 we could have
chameleon we could have scorpion I'm
sure they're saving those of course for
either Daredevil or Spider-Man But
ultimately I'm sure fans would just love
if the Sinister 6 consisted of people
like Norman Osborne Venom of course
eventually Dr Octopus and then we kind
of have vulture in the MCU right now
still not sure what they were doing in
morbius and with Sony and all of that
hopefully we get some clarification
about that pretty soon plus not to
mention after Avengers Secret Wars
they're said to be a soft reboot of the
MCU so that's their opportunity to kind
of do essentially whatever they want say
everything kind of exists in this
universe now all of these characters all
of these characters and also Multiverse
travel is possible now hopefully it's an
opportunity for Marvel Studios to kind
of clean everything up especially when
it's concerning Spider-Man because that
Sony spiderverse mix right now is rather
confusing as far as who exists in which
universe and if they allowed to cross
over between the Sony spiderverse and
the MCU Spider-Man movies but the main
point here is we are building up to
Kingpin to be a big bad of the street
level side of the MCU in fact Marvel
Studios has already confirmed this
executive Brad wbam when asked if
Kingpin was the next Thanos of the
street level side of the MCU he told the
interviewer you hit the nail on the head
confirming that is indeed what they are
doing so not only are we building up for
King Benin to be a major player in
Daredevil and Spider-Man but ultimately
there is going to be a street level
Avengers film that is going to have
Kingpin as the villain and basically all
the characters that have been
interconnected through Kingpin are going
to come together to take or try to take
him down this is going to be Daredevil
Spider-Man probably She-Hulk The
Punisher is supposed to appear in the
Daredevil series as well there's even
been rumors about Jessica Jones showing
up we essentially could have the
Defenders with some of the Avengers
going up against Kingpin in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe which would be
absolutely awesome and that is what this
Echo post credit scene is starting the
rise and reign of Kingpin in the MCU and
his reign will probably exist for a
while probably past Avengers Secret Wars
we know Spider-Man 4 is now scheduled to
come out before Avengers 5 originally it
was supposed to come out between
Avengers the King Dynasty and Avenger
Secret Wars but with everything with
Jonathan major happening they had to
move Spider-Man 4 up or I should say
they had to move Avengers 5 back so
expect kingping to appear in Daredevil
expect him to appear in Spider-Man 4 but
really expect him to just be a very
prominent figure in the MCO on the
street side moving forward and that's
really what this post-edit scene sets up
the start of Kingpin becoming mayor and
the start of a lot of problems for our
superheroes and Vigilantes out there so
let me know what you think about this in
the comments down below let me know what
you think about the eeko series I will
be putting out a review later so be on
the lookout for that but let me know
what you thought about Ekko please don't
forget to like this video And subscribe
so you can stay up to date on the MCU
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you are automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well the winner
picks one item and we pick one winner at
the end of each month you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof